this is a production of Cornell
University
grab so I thought I'd get asked a lot
about you know how long does it take to
get a variety out you know what is the
process so I thought I'd walk you
through what we did with Archer my
newest strawberry and it is it can be a
long process so the archer was a
selection I made very early in my career
here at Cornell and it was done very
much in the traditional sense of things
and so you'll see every step was done
through the field on a year-by-year
basis and it takes a long time doing it
that way so we've got some strategies
we've worked on and we'll talk about how
we've been speeding that up but this is
how Archer started so in 99 we made some
some crosses made some hybridizations I
didn't have a lot of information to go
on I hadn't worked on berries for very
long but we had the records from my
patent from the past breeder and we made
some crosses collected the seed in two
thousand that seed got treating got
planted out into the field you just grow
them in the field so we planted them in
rows and let them grow those have to
grow a year go through winter the next
spring we get to see fruit now we've
cleaned that up a little bit we use
plastic we put them on plastic to help
with weed control but the process is
generally the same we put them in the
ground one spring the next spring we get
to see fruit helps as well we use a
little bit of raised beds when you get a
lot of water this year that didn't
happen but last year we had water it was
so high it wet almost over the beds so
from some years we get a lot of rain and
some years yet none but you can't know
that in advance so in 2001 we made the
selection so this is a 2001 selection I
made some notes that day when I selected
it it's a huge king very often the
primary barrier that comes off of
strawberry in the industry they'll call
it the King berry I put very large q
well I use the term queen berry as well
rather than secondary because it's
easier to write but that's not generally
used in the industry and I wrote that it
was firm dat good interior color good
flavor tart that's what I had to go on I
made some notes that day and I picked
three fruit a primary barrier she a
secondary barrier in a tertiary very you
add those up it's almost a hundred grams
of fruit so I calculated if you took a
hundred grams of fruit which is only
three berries per plant on a per acre
basis that's over four thousand pounds
each plant produces more than three
fruit so this is the kind of thing when
we see this kind of thing we're like it
wow we got yield right away because we
got a lot of fruit size it comes off
very quickly and it comes off at once
and for us to have a tertiary Barry and
the 16 grams eyes is a very good berry
in the marketplace 25 will get you about
this big 50 50 50 grams will be about
the size of a plum it's a very large
berry that's larger than what you
normally see we like we'll pick berries
down to about 8 to 10 grams is
acceptable for a commercial product so
that year we had one plant that's all
there is is one plant from that one seed
so whatever runners it produced we
collected those runners routed them and
start and when there's a picture from
that first plant they're not the
prettiest things i'm out there holding
them with one hand taking a picture with
the other so it's really not i'm not a
photographer but it's for me it gets
into my head so i can look back and say
oh I remember that one and that's what
we do to have a picture of kind of a
record as we go you start a plot but it
took a year to make the runners then you
plant them again you got to wait another
year before they fruit again so that
takes a year we planted and then we look
at it for two or three years because we
want to see is it going to live it's
going to have some disease that wipes it
out in the first second year it's a
fruit going to grow or the plants going
to grow or they're going to produce
runners so we collect more runners from
the next plot and then you plant another
plot and you do it again to make sure
because you got a planet in different
locations to make sure you didn't plan
it in the best possible location and it
was great but in a bad location it's
going to die very quickly so we planted
multiple plots at different locations so
that we can see this over time
and then you have to evaluate it for
several years to see how it comes
through winter to see how the plants
grow will they persist in the field will
it have a good yield every year it takes
time to go through this and it can
really take a long time and during that
way most of the selections gets left off
they're found wanting for whatever
reason they're susceptible to some
disease they don't produce enough
runners the fruit quality declines over
time these are things that you see we
take more pictures so we all make sure
we're planting the same plant every time
and that when you it produces fruit the
fruit looks like what we think it's
supposed to look like so each time you
each cycle you're taking pictures to
make sure everything is the same at that
point we decided these are looking good
they're very consistent we're going to
move it into tissue culture because to
take it off the station we needs
disease-free plants I can't collect
stuff from the field and send it out to
growers or to a nursery and it could
have any kind of pathogen on it so we
move it into tissue culture to clean it
up make sure it doesn't have any viruses
make sure it doesn't have buy tops or up
verticillium various fungal pathogens
and that takes can take it a few months
but it could take a year or more to some
some varieties don't tissue culture well
so we got plants we have to check in for
virus we have to produce more plants so
we can put them back out in the field
make sure tissue culture didn't screw it
up sometimes you put things in tissue
culture what you get out of tissue
culture doesn't look like what you put
in and so we have to make sure that we
grow plants make sure they're true to
type make sure they look like what you
expect them to look like all this takes
time and we of course take more pictures
we want to make sure it looks like it's
supposed to look like you have to make
sure you have the same product that you
in the end with of what you started with
so we confirmed trueness of type at that
stage we're like okay we got virus free
plants let's send it to the nursery so
they can propagate it in large numbers
that way we can get it to some of the
growers so in 2014 we sent out sixteen
thousand plus plants to different 11
growers across the state so they could
grow it in a large scale and give me
some feedback on how how it looks for
them how does it look in a commercial
setting up to that point we had 25-foot
plots at the biggest you know so now
they get a thousand plants or two
thousand plants and you can see it on a
van a core a quarter of an acre and
actually see it in a large scale they
evaluated the first year they evaluate
it again the second year if you want to
sit most of the growers will grow it in
a perennial setting and they want to see
it more than one year so all this takes
15 years we get to this point and we're
finally okay it's time to release it and
you're here today it's being released
today it's being announced so it is
available to growers now they won't plan
it until next year but of course we're
taking pictures all along to make sure
that it's the same thing question
yes
so what the growers will pay what the
growers will do or what the nursery will
charge the propagation fee so that the
cost of propagation is offset so it is
not the same price that is its we're not
selling the plants they're offsetting
the cost of propagation it's a semantics
but it is not available to commercial
growers in this kate was only available
to growers of the New York State berry
Growers Association through a
cooperative agreement with Cornell
University that we have with the
Association so we didn't send it to just
any growers we sent it to growers who
were part of this organization that we
had a contract with for doing the
testing and so this was this year this
is fruit I got from a commercial grower
it looked great he was happy with it we
moved forward so that it's now going to
be available and they will plant the
first commercial crop this coming spring
in 2017 of course we won't see that
fruit until 2018 so again there's time
every time you have to grow the plant so
it can really take a long time to get
through it so how do we
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu